let's talk about Tyreke he'll the Kansas
City Chiefs wide receiver who is being
investigated according to the Kansas
City Star in Overland Park police who
say they are investigating two incidents
including one where a source from the
star believes that his three-year-old
son broke his arm that's not they're not
investigating the three-year-old son
broke his arm they're investigating that
Tyreke Hill broke his son's arm right
yeah he didn't say I said it was
domestic assault case yeah I think if we
can put it together
no you just they don't if they
investigate the son broke his arm but
they're saying Tyreke did it it wasn't
the mom he didn't just fall
he didn't fall out of a tree
Tyreke Hill broke his own son's arm well
they haven't charged them yet so that's
its little that's what they're
investigating that's the story I'm
allegedly it's a it's a domestic
violence story with the twist you know
means a kid this time which I always
enjoy I accept we do a lot of you know
beating up women I don't like that it's
a boy it's a three-year-old boy then we
can have some fun with the topic even I
mean then we can kind of mess around my
saw the story my first thought was what
did the kid do you know I mean they
never asked that when he was the running
back who beat his kid with Adrian
Peterson never explained what his kid
did to deserve that you know I mean he
was like that I punished my kids
sometimes I hit him a little too hard
he never said like if you've been like
the kid you know put oatmeal in my DVD
player then he'd be like okay maybe you
were justified so I want to know what
Tyree killed like what the kid did the
Tyree kill had to allegedly break his
three-year-old son's arm over his knee
which is how I imagine it that's how I
imagine he broke the arm what would you
how would you picture it Greg I wouldn't
and they maybe threw him down some
stairs kind of thing or like just picked
him up by an arm and broke it well maybe
they were playing while you say you know
it's kind of more fun to play around
with the kid you know angle of it it
doesn't involve the kids mom as an other
person involved kind of separate and she
was also someone he beat up in a
domestic assault
College and pled guilty to it and now
while she was pregnant with this kid how
did he there's levels at level Ric how
did he get drafted if he got if he got
charged with domestic violence in
college how did that had that slip
through the cracks of the NFL he got he
had drafted a little later did people
find out after he got drafted that
people knew at a time yeah it was their
chance that the kid broke his arm when
Tyree killed beat beat up his pregnant
mom and then they didn't find out about
it until later on three years I've never
seen you guys so uncomfortable with the
story before I hope we use this as part
of the YouTube video because Greg is so
uncomfortable
America gasped which I've never heard
before listen it's a three-year-old look
I made it through the craft week getting
his I can survive by his own father yeah
you know how was Tyree killed this year
as a player you've a good season he was
good enough that there was a report on
our network about a month ago that they
were discussing a contract which might
make him the highest-paid wide receiver
in the league really okay that was
before the summer so he earned this in a
way you know what I mean you're allowed
and listen here's the thing you break an
arm you break a bone in your body this
is science you break a bone in your body
it grows its heels and stronger than
ever before you can never break in that
place again isn't that what parenting is
all about you know preparing your
children is that what is this medical
science you speak of no that's right
that for it's a fact if you wouldn't
want to bone breaks when it heals you
can never break the bone in that same
place it's like it's it's break proof
that's the medical term break proof if
you if you're a doctor you listening to
this you make it sound like it's one of
those like lizards where you cut the
head off and they can grow again grow
like another arm if you cut off the tip
of a baby's finger it will grow back I
saw that on Twitter once on a WTF fax
that that's it that's true as a result
there may be a brief period in the
healing process when the fracture site
is stronger than the surrounding bone a
brief period but they later reach equal
strength then the fracture site is no
more or less likely to break again would
you
New York Times song I thought in general
if you like break a leg you're more
likely to break it because it just shows
you're kind of prone to it now you're
thinking about dislocating a jaw line or
a leg or something yeah then it's gonna
happen all the time so he Tyreke L
didn't do that he was smart enough not
to dislocate his son's arm but I want to
know what the kid did you know maybe
like listen okay if Walker hadn't turned
it around and what look again Walker's
for he's probably past the age where you
couldn't break his arm but if he's three
then I think sometimes you got to teach
him a lesson and there's no better
lesson than breaking him hidden burn the
kid which he could have done depending
on what the kid did I don't know maybe
the kid didn't do anything and Tyreke
he'll confused him for another kid that
did something what would seem it would
seem that no matter what a
three-year-old did it you know it
wouldn't be worthy of breaking his arm I
mean not from me you know but again I'm
not a father I don't know I don't know
the joy of being a father and
disciplining your own child that neither
do i you've never actually I guess I can
tell I've been around your kids they're
never been disciplined but if they were
my kids they'd be in cast right now a
Jesus Christ statue no in this small
video it's not a statue they called it a
statue whether were you they it's a doll
but they call it a statue because it's
up in a house and they they have it
prominently he's played all who statue
by putting it up in a house that's what
they call it that's what they're calling
it
residents of a small village in Acapulco
Mexico are concerned because they claim
that for the fourth time this year this
baby Jesus doll has started crying blood
my favorite part of the story is that
their acts I've read the story and it
was like a doll that they claimed as a
baby Jesus doll like it's not like an
official like TM baby Jesus doll it's
just a baby doll that they're like this
could be Jesus it looks like it looks
just like a regular baby doll yeah I'm a
little confused why it's a baby Jesus
doll it looks like young girl especially
with the like very
professional-looking blood coming out of
its eyes it looks like a girl that Tyree
killed baby says allegedly it it's a
baby wearing like a bib to like his
Jesus wearing a bib and a hat that says
bear on it so I thought the baby doll
would have like a beard and long hair
but it doesn't and that's what Jesus was
all about from birth if you guys read
the story of the nativity scene baby
Jesus full beard yeah so they are
concerned in this village that but
aren't they excited they're like oh this
is like some people think it's a good
thing like this is like God saying hey
what's up Acapulco rules well and some
people are saying oh maybe it's the
devil right one woman said a lot of yeah
a lot of people have said it's done by
the devil others think it's a message
from God they believe that the statues
crying is in direct response to the
amount of murders in that village in
which there are many and it's not just
crying it's crying blood crisis a whole
nother level so it happened first on New
Year's Day and it's happened three more
times since this year and what like I
don't I would love to know who noticed
at first it was like hey what's in
someone's house no one's like hey is
that ketchup like I don't believe that
dogs cry blood that's probably not a
baby Jesus doll like dolls mostly don't
cry blood did you play with dolls in
your kid
Erika did any of them cry blood ever
never not even when he rapped no no
because I would think that would do it
Greg did you how do you feel about this
Jesus doll do you think it's legit I
mean I thought the most telling part of
the story was from an unnamed priest who
said the and representative of the
Catholic Church it will maybe go to this
person's house because they're afraid to
bring the baby doll into the local
church because that might upset God and
so they want to leave it where it is but
he he said the Catholic Church is gonna
come they're gonna check it out and he
did admit a rational explanation could
be at play here because not everything
is a spiritual phenomena that's true you
think whoa oh that sarcasm at the end I
love it
the church can find a miracle if they
need it you know I mean if you wanted to
make a new Saint it's like oh this was a
kind of a miracle but if you actually
say what about this maybe the Bible is
full of stuff that you wouldn't believe
now if you were like hey Erica turned
water into wine is that a miracle maybe
she's sandy be like no it's total
you read it in the Bible and a
the King James Version I don't know how
many versions you've read but the King
James is the best one then they're like
oh that's totally that makes perfect
sense that's what happened I just like
like wait how does this become a story
like how does this like whose idea was
it to try to make this a story there are
two kinds of stories coming out of
Mexico one is there's a caravan coming
another one is a drug dealer shot up a
lot of people and the third one is Jesus
is crying it happens all the time what
was there wasn't like a Virgin Mary
statue
yes very similar or not it was sewage
like I'm he was like backed up sewage a
very similar one happened last year yes
yeah and so my thought was probably you
know the doll people whoever has this in
their house thought that got some good
pop they're upset about all the murders
going on in town and you know they
gussied up this doll with some high
blood you know I could I call myself an
atheist or a NAPA theist I don't care if
there's a god one of our here about a
baby doll oh Jesus baby doll crying
blood I think you know what who knows
for sure maybe there is a heaven and I
don't want to go there
[Music]
you